what we're looking at this morning is
just one more illustration of how
complex numbers in a real way is kind of
like the apex of so much mathematics
that you've been learning over the last
11 years right it's like all these nuts
loose packing in geometry intrigue even
just in normal number arithmetic and
stuff like that
it leads here and it finds its like it's
crescendo here okay our trigonometric
identities you've been learning them on
to unit an extension one for quite some
time now but we sort of stopped at a
certain point because it becomes
impractical to go any further so let me
try and illustrate that for you right
put your extension one hat on okay and
let's just think about some of the basic
tree extensions like these two okay we
can court these results can't we decide
to theater is and cos 2theta on the
other end is closed squared minus sine
squared sine squared okay now where did
these come from where do we get these
from how do we prove that these were the
case does anyone remember what do these
yeah good so this is this double angle
formula it's really just a specific
instance of when you're adding two
angles together then any two angles one
for instance sign your a plus B where a
and B are the same angle and then your
two Mabel's become a double angle
formula okay now we have a result for
this because a signed a plus sign a cos
B that's the extension and the
corresponding one for cost where did
that come from when did it begin in
awhile now I this is not a it's not a
proof you need so there's no that big a
deal if you've forgotten it are we
you generally and there's a whole
variety of ways to do this but generally
we sort of construct some funky
triangles that relate to each other and
there's gonna be you know for example
the construction that I know to top my
head
something like this that and then you've
got name 88 and go be here and when you
go around you do use all the right angle
triangles and you say look site a plus B
there's sign a plus B right will be we
really opposite on hypotenuse so all you
have to do is work out what those are in
terms of the geometry of this
construction that you make and unpack
comes your identity right so we went
from here to here to here okay and this
is generally when we stop now once upon
a time and going further than this was
in the syllabus was mandated you needed
to know more identities than just this
for instance you need to know this and
the corresponding one for cosine right
so aptly named these are the triple
angle formulas now using the knowledge
that you have now or how would you go
about developing this formula yeah me
too this is just again another instance
of this guy right except my a and B are
two theta
Peter I think you can kind of sift it
down from there and there's no there's
no problem with that I think you can't
actually get this result let's just
quickly have a go and remembering trig
identities mean that there's a variety
of ways it's a same thing innocent same
things in the simplest form but let's
just have a go and see what we get done
right if the sine 2 theta plus it this
is that a and B just what's our tough
straight extension of this using using
this start with it cause yeah very good
okay now that's true but it's not
particularly simple what else could I do
from here where else could I go I've got
a pair of double that angle identity but
I can take advantage of them so excuse
me over here I've got that close to
theta I could write it as cos squared
minus sine squared but B now I want to
simplify down as far as I possibly can
it might be better to write it as
remember there's a couple other forms to
this guy to remember what the other
forms are okay so that cause squared
using the Pythagorean identity is 1
minus sine squared so being that there's
another minus sign squared on there I
could write it like so that would work
what was the other form 2 squared minus
1 because you just take instead of
translating that into 1 minus sine
squared you translate that into 1 minus
cos squared and out it comes okay which
one would you prefer
one or two interestingly just by
convention okay can I say out of out of
these two there is not one that is more
obviously simple than young like they're
they're both quadratics in a basic trig
function okay so I don't think one is
clearer than the other but by convention
because it starts with sign most people
wanted in terms of sign like that's
that's what I'm converting down here
does that make sense
so in some ways what I'm about to do is
arbitrary but it's often words people
arbitrarily do so I'm going to
substitute 1 minus 2 sine squared okay I
know what sine 2 theta is it's right
there okay so I've got 2 sine theta now
I would normally write cos theta up
but there's another cos theta hanging on
the end there right so this is cos
squared theta now there's one more
substitution that I can make right let's
expand this and then do that
substitution so here I've got sine theta
takeaway to side cute okay over here I'm
gonna have 2 sine theta times what is
sine squared and now you can kind of see
why oh now now everything's in terms of
sines and I've gotten rid of all of my
double or triple angles or anything so
it's objectively at least I think this
is simpler right um how would I simplify
this or like a left I've got a sine
theta plus 2 sine theta
that's all of my just regular sine-theta
says so it looks like three signing up
to me and then what else do I have
yeah there's ways to cite QT and then
there will be another minus two sine
cubed here - okay no search - for sign
cubes
I suppose I could now at this point
factorize out a sine theta but most
people do not they just kind of leave it
there okay this that was not
unreasonable like going from here to
here or was it like a crazy number of
lines but you can start to realize this
is not if you remember back when we were
on come back for a second into the
complex world for a minute and when we
were solving this we could solve this in
rectangular form do you remember that
like I didn't need to appeal to modern
form to do this okay I could do this and
then I could factorize this guy I could
say this and then your linear
factorization is not that hard okay
but then when I said well when we look
at this you're like ah gross
right like I can't factorize it but it's
gonna be terrible
like in polynomial terms it's it's kind
of gross right so therefore the
rectangular way even though it worked it
didn't end up being very versatile it
didn't take us very far it was a method
that quickly ran into like an upper
limit for where it was practical right
and can you can you see the same thing
is happening here right do you really
want to do sign for theta 5 beta or 16
up like this is how bad it was just for
free okay
I don't even want to go there so
therefore the question is bigger than
that complex numbers and particularly
democracy right have connected us to a
way of thinking about angles and when
they increase at am as as in multiples
right because that's what appears in two
more verses there you got the sine n
theta and the clothes n theta they're
inside the brackets right how can we
take advantage of that